I've learned that you can't live in fear
you wanted to be a star ever since you
were a little kid does and you made your
dream come true you never stopped
believing in yourself even when the
going got rough you're truly an
inspiration before becoming a huge
Broadway star and well established
triple threats you were just an average
kid with a big dream well dubs dreams
really do come true we know all about
the descendents stars and where they're
going but we don't really know about
where they've been keep watching us we
were built of your favorite descendant
stars before and after they got famous
Jada Marie the mischievous and
unpredictable Celia faseler is played by
Jada Marie a super talented young star
who got her first acting gig on man &
wife back in 2015 Jada has changed so
much since she first rose to fame it's
hard to believe she's only 14 years old
talk about a glow up and a cast cards
and a cat card gave us the dizzy
Jermaine we all deserve she's a fan
favorite for obvious reasons and she's
just getting started the 16 year old
actress landed her first gig on odd
squad back in 2016 and quickly climbed
the Disney Channel ladder to success
anna has changed so much in just four
short years Diane don't die and owned
landed her first acting gig in 2009 and
it would be another six years before she
was cast as Lani in The Descendants
franchise she didn't become a Disney
Channel star and how she was 25 years
old
Diane's appearance hasn't really changed
in the last 10 years
what's your secret Diane Jedidiah
Goodacre
Jedidiah Goodacre portrayed the arrogant
Chad charming in all three descendants
films believe it or not but Jedediah was
the oldest actor to play one of the
Disney's descendants Jedediah started
acting six years ago when he was 24
years old his face shape has changed a
great deal and he's ditched the overalls
for a more classic attire
Brenna's Domingo the sweet and innocent
James portrayed by actress Brenna
Domingo while it's hard to believe
Brenda had blond hair when she was a
little girl which is funny since The
Descendants star is known for her dark
wavy hair and
striking blue eyes she started acting
when she was 15 years old and has
changed so much since she rose to fame
Thomas Daugherty 24-year old actor
Thomas Daugherty has come a long way
since playing Harry hook in The
Descendants franchise Thomas landed his
first role in 2013 before starring as
Shawn Matthews in Disney's the lodge
Thomas's style has changed tremendously
since becoming famous clearly Thomas was
made for the limelight just like his
girlfriend dove Cameron Sarah Jeffery
the big fat Audrey is played by Canadian
actress Sarah Jeffery Sarah started
acting in 2013 when she was 16 years old
but her career really took off when she
scored the role of Audrey just two years
later Sarah posted an adorable video of
herself when she was 9 years old on
Instagram little did little Sarah know
she'd be a huge star in under 7 years
china and the claim while most people
know Chyna and McClain as the Disney
star who played uma many others have
watched her grow up on the small screen
China started acting when she was seven
years old landing her first gig in 2005
China style has changed a lot since
graduating from high school in 2016
Mitchell hope King VIN is played by
actor Mitchell Hope who is currently 25
years old it's time for new beginnings
Mitchell had appeared in a few short
films before starring in The Descendants
franchise he had the look of a
fresh-faced teen down pat but now
Mitchell is all set to play more
age-appropriate roles
Zackary Gibson before snagging the role
of Evie's on-screen lover Doug Zackary
Gibson had appeared in the 2014 TV movie
zapped and just one year later
Zachary became a Disney star by the time
the descendents franchise came to an end
in 2019 Zachary was almost
unrecognizable thanks to his long hair
and wild beard booboo Stewart
unlike many Disney Channel stars booboo
Stewart was already a well-established
actor and model when he walked onto the
descendents set booboo has been acting
since 2003 and now the 25 year old actor
is all grown up and ready to take on the
next challenge
Sophia Carson
maybe the fashion designer
extraordinaire is portrayed by Sophia
Carson and believe it or not the
descendants was the first movie Sophia
was ever cast in my mom's Queen which
makes me a princess so if you became a
Disney Channel star in 2014 and quickly
rose to fame by the time the descendants
franchise wrapped up production when it
comes to fashion Sophia doesn't mess
around
Dillon play fair the hilariously
absent-minded gill is played by actor
Dylan play fair in 2012 when Dylan was
20 years old he made his grand debut in
Grave Encounters - and now seven years
later
Dylan is an established actor who has
kept himself busy since leaving the cast
of descendants Cameron voice the late
Cameron Boyce was born to bring joy and
laughter to kids all around the globe
and he knew this from a very young age
Cameron started acting when he was nine
years old and quickly became a beloved
Disney Channel star he stole our hearts
as Carlos in descendants and we loved
watching him grow up before our very
eyes
dove Cameron and last but not least his
dove Cameron who is known for playing
mal in The Descendants franchise the 23
year old Broadway star started acting in
2012 and hasn't looked back since
dove didn't have the easiest childhood
but she followed her passions which
helped to become the star she is today
which one of the descendants actors had
the best to blow up sound off in the
comments thanks for watching we hope you
enjoyed our video give us a big thumbs
up and don't forget to subscribe for
more fun videos like this one we'll see
you next time on the things
[Music]